hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to suicide now I saw this
game on Steam it was on sale and then
Ethan Rebecca mended it to me so I have
no idea what it's about but it looks
like a mixture of goat simulator and I'm
just gonna go into a game alright oh
it's a multiplayer game is it oh it's a
multiplayer game I didn't even know
alright then okay
I even in this game I didn't seem are we
supposed to keep Oh
oh my god simulator what is that what is
that I've got 100
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's an axe [ __ ] you I'll take the axe
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm freaking out here
this is the craziest game I've ever seen
in my entire life
oh good so I just gotta keep an eye out
for animals this works there's like a
point system if there's a responder if
there's like an objective but the
gorilla is dead well there ain't no
giraffe in the enclosure so me am
assuming that something is suspicious
around here so mark a monkey on a case
there's a trail of destruction here oh
my god okay bye [ __ ] am I supposed to
hunt him down so they must be hide it
wolf [ __ ] you they must be hiding I'll
just crack the top of my skull oh I hear
you boy here more steps than me I'm
sorry it's just the carcasses of the
dead girl oh my god they're all
decapitated so how do I find him I mean
you wouldn't think it would be hard to
find a giraffe oh my god you bunny oh
there he is
I'm coming for you
if you [ __ ] chop oh my god he's gonna
let hey I'm on your team I think what
what is happening with my body right now
well I am just one leg I can't do
anything can I I can't oh my god switch
to dead human switch did a dead human
dead human captive ostrich oh he's fine
I should have gone after him oh good
okay well the Kangaroos dead giraffe is
still tussle no drafts dead now okay and
then it's just that one guy with an axe
Oh
Mega Mike okay Mega Mike can you finish
off the ostrich and get this over with I
think that's my mood shoe Oh player has
quit does that mean we can win now of
the stare of my dead corpse and hope
that's something else oh he took my moon
shoe piece of Garbo [ __ ] that guy yeah
you hey can you check my prostate while
you're looking there sorry I'm just
quivering in anticipation oh my god oh
my god oh this poor ostrich here we go
the final showdown okay he quit
oh I can see them well then why can't
they see me oh hey okay alright then
thank you tip stepping out there alright
go that way
bazookas there's a freaking bazookas
down here why can't I get a bazooka oh
can I get a bazooka I just stopped that
yeah
nope that's like nope alright Scott stop
stop humping the ground it's really
disturbing
alright Alvis radical Oh like a real old
Hey what all right oh I'm not gonna oh I
got problems up here you know what let's
go for it whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
we won
I killed Mike her fellow girls I think
what am I think we won oh my god that is
the [ __ ] funniest game I wanna do one
more round just one more just one more
round
just one more round to v3 animals I got
it I got me and Maddy we got this
oh I saw someone jumping that was an
explosion alright got me this roller
skates
Oki Abra well I go super fast oh [ __ ]
catch me Oh dual wielding chainsaw
it's please on rollerskates [ __ ] yeah
bruh
[ __ ] yeah bruh Kimberly for some of this
[Music]
I am at the heaven
hope you guys are okay with hearing
nothing but chainsaw for the next ten
hours maybe chainsaws are the best idea
oh where are they let me go down there
see if I can find someone gasps I think
I'm out again you know I don't think I'm
prepared yes I am now come here you
[Music]
this should be working right oh [ __ ]
this doesn't work I think this is only
meant for bagels let me go for the this
whatever this is can I shoot you okay
I didn't expect that to actually work
hello anybody home my name is markiplier
get ready that's a gorilla head this is
a chainsaw I can't use that really scary
oh it's a scary is that it no it's a
spent one I split beneath here we go
there we go
want some [ __ ] I have it right dude
okay I got a gun there's a gun now it's
me to get a gun against the world all
right who do we got left who's left in
captivity
no one oh hi oh you want some oh that's
what this is for buddy come come at me
headshot come at me bro you want some of
this yeah [ __ ] you up any day bruh oh is
that right in your noggin line fire in
this big noscope yep this chainsaw might
be just appropriate for if someone of
that height now it's a fair fight don't
you run from me
runnin from me boy you running from me
grab [ __ ] ah this is not on anymore
Jade's always off come on come on I love
that there's more modes
yeah all-out animal warfare that's so
cool this game was so cheap that's all
the time I got for this game let me know
what you think down in the comments
below I'll put a link to the game in the
description as well this was oh man look
out for market monkey if you play this
for yourself or anyone with a marketable
art style name so thank you again
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]